tag zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live mit wellen kennen wir uns
mittlerweile ja doch ein bisschen aus
die erste zweite und dritte welle die
haben wir hinter uns und die vierte
welle die vierte corona welle scheint im
anmarsch zu sein manche sagen aber auch
die ist schon längst da der chef des
robert koch-instituts herr wieder zum
beispiel der in einer präsentation vor
den chefs der staatskanzleien der
bundesländer davor gewarnt dass die
krankenhäuser im winter und herbst
wieder voll werden könnten vor allem
wenn nicht genug menschen geimpft werden
und das wird natürlich einige fragen auf
zum beispiel gibt es diese vierte welle
eigentlich schon wie schlimm kann die
ganze welle werden und was ist am besten
jetzt zu tun das wollen wir heute
sprechen mit professor ulrike protzer
die ist direktorin des instituts für
virologie an der tu münchen und am
helmholtz zentrum in münchen und
natürlich wie immer mit euch und mit
ihnen fragen kommentare wie immer in die
dafür vorgesehene kommentarspalte oder
per e mail an zdf heute - live at zdf.de
wird mir dann hier eingereicht und ich
schaue sie immer was ich von euren
fragen mitnehmen kann bevor ganz
arbeiten diese diskussion stürzen die
auch gerade in der politik heiß geführt
wird fasst thomas ganz normal diese
position des rk ii die da präsentiert
wurde von den chefs der staatskanzleien
zusammen für uns die sieben tage
incidents also die zahl der
neuansteckungen pro 100.000 einwohnern
binnen einer woche sie steigt und steigt
seit gut drei wochen aktueller stand 15
und seit langem ist sie etabliert diese
sieben tage incidents als entscheidendes
maß des corona geschehens
das soll auch so bleiben sagen das
robert koch institut und rk ii chef
wähler denn das rk ii beobachtet mit
steigender incidents mehr
krankenhausfälle 0,37 pro 100.000
einwohnern aktuell das bedeute mehr
fälle gleich mehr kranke und mögliche
tote heißt erstens die inzidenz
prognostiziert das ausmaß schwerer
verläufe und alle zahlen zu schweren
verläufen kommen mit verzögerung auf zu
spät und zu reagieren heißt zweitens die
inzidenz ist so jedenfalls das lka der
früheste wichtige indikator des corona
geschehens uns darüber möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit frau professor ulrike
protzer direktorin des instituts für
virologie an der tu münchen und am
helmholtz zentrum in münchen
hallo frau protz mit seiner auffassung
widerspricht hall wieder ja doch einigen
menschen also zum beispiel den
bundesgesundheitsminister ganz sparen
der hat vor einigen wochen erklärt also
der enns der inzidenz fed wird an
aussagekraft verlieren
da gab es dann dieses geflügelte wort
200 ist das neue 50 also eine höhere
instanz könnte man sich jetzt erlauben
eben weil gefährdete gruppen geimpft
sind und dass deswegen weniger
krankenhauseinweisungen geben würde
jetzt gibt es auch ländervertreter und
wissenschaftler innen die mit wie das
ansicht nicht einverstanden sind wie
sehen sie das denn ich denke wenn man
die inzidenz als marker für das
infektionsgeschehen etwas schon okay
wenn man sie als marker für die
relevanten infektion die hatte das
gesundheitssystem belasten das heißt das
krankheitsgeschehen nimmt dann ist sie
einfach nicht mehr so aussagekräftig wie
sie war bevor wir jetzt die
risikogruppen geimpft haben dh 200 ist
das neue 50 würden sie auch so
unterschreiben
ich glaube an das differenzieren wen es
trifft wir haben jetzt mit sehr guten
quoten bei den älteren bei den
gefährdeten die wirklich in der letzten
welle im winter uns die ganz großen
probleme gemacht haben da wir schon im
februar märz gesehen dass die zahlen
einfach drastisch runter gehen und die
sind hoffentlich hoffe dass die impfung
so lange
man hält auch durch den winter durch
noch geschützt das heißt es dann familie
die mich gehen und die jüngeren aber die
jüngeren wie gern noch nicht so stark
krank also man muss hier glaube ich
deutlich differenziert daran gehen als
das eben im letzten winter der fall
das würde ja heißen dass wir den
incidents wert so nicht mehr als maßstab
nehmen können für bestimmte
verhaltensmaßnahmen oder vielleicht auch
für beschränkungen
da gibt es auch andere wissenschaftler
die das so sehen
der virologe und epidemiologe klaus
stört er hat sich schon in der
vergangenheit öfter dazu kritisch
geäußert zu sagen dass der install
incidents wird quasi das maß aller dinge
ist wir haben den heute auch noch mal
interviewt und da hat er bei uns
gefordert dass das alter der erkrankten
mit beachtet wird wir hören mal rein was
er gesagt hat wir werden jetzt sagen wir
mal bei den über 60-jährigen die melde
intelligent ansteigen dann wird auch
eine ganz normal bei denen die sind ja
dann so ein großer geste oder eben auch
nicht geben
dann würden die auch irgendwann mal auf
die intensivstation kommen oder sterben
also das würde schon im frühling hat
auch mit seien aber muss es
altersgruppen spezifisch machen und
natürlich auch sich anschauen und
diejenigen geimpft oder nicht das würde
auf jeden fall besser sein als jetzt
wieder die gießkannen incident zu nehmen
denn dann rechnet ja auch berechnen sich
die jugend die jungen mit rein dann wenn
man 100 asymptomatische kinder hat in
einer stadt von 100.000 in der woche
dann machen die geschäfte schon wieder
zu sinkt aber nichts mehr keiner krank
wird wasser wären weitere parameter
nicht wichtiger ist die
krankenhauseinweisung häufigkeit hat die
schweiz zum beispiel als dem parameter
120 am tag und mehr dann muss was
unternommen werden und wenn man dann
noch wirklich weiter greifen will da
kommen natürlich dann die
intensivstation dazu und die sterbefälle
so also noch mehr daten nehmen um zu
entscheiden was man machen sollte jetzt
gibt es aber auch zum beispiel biologen
hat dem stürmer der auch öfter bei uns
noch ein gespräch war er hat heute im
zdf gesagt eröffnet die inzidenz nach
wie vor wichtig eben weil die ja vorher
sagt wie sich weiter das krankenhaus
geschehen ausbreiten kann wie würden sie
das denn sehen vor professor protzer
ich glaube herr stürmer hat schon recht
die inzidenz ist sicherlich ein
wichtiger parameter weil das zeigt ganz
einfach an wie ist das
infektionsgeschehen was meint ihr wissen
wir wollen ja wissen wie an welchem ort
gibt es wie viele infektionen
das zweite was wir aber wissen wollen
ist welche krankheitslast lösen diese
infektionen aus und das sagt uns die
inzidenz alleine nicht weil da kommt
nämlich dazu welches alter welche
risikofaktoren haben diejenigen die sich
infizieren und daher schlagen wir
eigentlich schon lange als parameter die
zahl der krankenhauseinweisungen vor
weil wir sehr exakt ist man geht ja
nicht ins krankenhaus einfach so aus
spaß sondern wirklich weil man krank ist
und die kann man regional aufgelöst um
der tages genau bestimmen
und ich glaube wenn man diese beiden
parameter hat dann hat man schon ein
sehr gutes gefühl wie ist das
infektionsgeschehen und wie ist das
dadurch bedingte krankheitsgeschehen
müsste man dann nicht doch die zahl der
geimpften beziehungsweise der
ungeimpften mit rein nehmen dann wird
man auch sagen kann okay wir haben in
der region sagt jetzt mal also sachsen
ist zb ein land wo es noch relativ
niedrigen impfzahlen gibt im vergleich
zu anderen bundesländern dass man sagt
okay hier könnte es kritisch werden weil
wir einfach mehr menschen haben die noch
nicht geschützt sind das heißt hier
werden wir weder einen ähnlichen verlauf
kriegen wie vor einem halben jahr
natürlich ist es wichtig zu wissen wie
viele menschen geimpft sind aber
infizieren werden sich noch tun sich ja
hauptsächlich die nicht gehen sondern
auch ins krankenhaus kommen
hauptsächlich gemischt
insofern geben einem diese beiden
parameter zusätzlich noch auskunft
darüber
und wir sind glaube ich der bessere
steuerung parameter als jetzt alleine in
all ihren es gibt es eine spannende
frage von raimund bollinger auf facebook
der schreibt die 50er incidents war doch
wegen der kontakt verfolgung durch die
gesundheitsämter eingeführt worden
ich erinnere das war tatsächlich damals
so dass sein gesagt wurde also bis
hierhin kann man die kontakte noch
einigermaßen gut nachverfolgen danach
wird es schwierig
und dann sagt er weiter wenn man aber
erst bei incidents 800 zum beispiel
gegensteuern möchte ich sag jetzt mal
vielleicht noch niedriger 400 ist ja
auch schon ein höherer wert wie soll
dann die kontakt verfolgung aussehen
also ist das dann überhaupt noch möglich
also dann
überlassen wir ja quasi die
gesundheitsämter sehenden auges wieder
oder das wird absolut zu sein wenn wir
hohe inzidenz haben wären die
gesundheitsämter probleme haben die
einzelnen fälle nachzuverfolgen
und deswegen ist es schon auch wichtig
dass man so beschrieb das gefühl dafür
hat das infektionsgeschehen und wie hoch
ist die inzidenz dann das will man
natürlich nicht komplett außen oder
laufen lassen aber die frage ist ja
welche maßnahmen folgen dann daraus
heißt es also wir müssen wieder kontakt
beschränkungen verschärfen heißt es wir
müssen vielleicht sogar weitergehende
maßnahmen treffen und da ist ja dann
doch wichtig lösen die infektionen auch
eine krankheit auslösen die in
krankheitsgeschehen aus also man wird
dann einfach deutlich differenzierter
agieren
trauen sie dass ich sage das mal den
behörden zu dir doch in den letzten
jahren gezeigt haben dass sie schnell an
die kapazitätsgrenze kommen dass man
wirklich das so differenziert sich
betrachten kann man sagen kann ok hier
müssen wir so vorgehen und hier müssen
wir so vorgehen
ich habe schon die entscheidung über
diese dinge fällt ja die politik nicht
die behörden wir gehören sind ja
letztendlich diejenigen die das ganze
dann aus vielen gut aber die war ja auch
eine deutlich überfordert den letzten
monaten immer wieder streitet sich jetzt
auch gerade wieder kommen wenngleich zu
über die testpflicht absolut aber die
frage ist ja was wollen wir verhindern
wollen wir hin wollen wir verhindern
dass das gesundheitsamt überlastet ist
oder wollen wir verhindern dass die
krankenhäuser überlastet werden und eben
dort nicht nur menschen mit pro bit dann
probleme haben sondern ganz ganz viele
andere auch das ist ja das was uns
treibt es geht ja nicht nur um die
patienten die mit coop 19 aus kommen
sondern es geht ja darum wenn die
krankenhäuser zu viele patienten haben
können sie die anderen nicht mehr
vernünftig versorgen
dann werden operationen verschoben dann
werden tumor vorsorgen verschoben und
genau das ist ja das was man eben nicht
ich habe ja auch kommentare jetzt zum
beispiel hier vom ksb
er schreibt wenn noch ein lockout kommt
dann war's das mit der gesellschaft du
kannst lindner meint auch auf youtube
nach krankenhauseinweisungen zu
entscheiden ist absolut richtig und
raimund dem ich auch qualität hat er
möchte wissen ob es das lila papier
irgendwo 21
gibt man dass es kein offizielles habt
ihr das war eine präsentation die ihr
gehalten hat vor den chefs der
staatskanzleien ist also gar nicht
offiziell herausgegeben worden trotzdem
war das die presse bekommen wir auch und
können jetzt daraus zitieren und in
dieser präsentation steht eben auch die
vierte welle ist längst da können sie
das so unterschreiben frau professor
protzer das kommt sicherlich darauf an
in welches land man schaut also schauen
wir nach england schauen wir wie
niederlanden wir schauen wir nach
spanien wird man sagen die grippewelle
ist da die dritte welle an infektionen
nicht unbedingt die kältewelle am
krankenhaus belastung ich glaube mir
willst du das wirklich differenzieren in
deutschland haben wir das glück dass die
zahlen immer noch niedrig sind
aber auch hier befürchte ich das
wirklich nicht so halten lassen
das wird in den herbst rein sicherlich
wieder ansteigen
ich schaue mal kurz ich suche gerade
nochmal hier die präsentation die ich
auch hatte aber jetzt nicht mehr auf
habt da ist tatsächlich nicht drin doch
da habe ich sie augenblick da können sie
mal kurz auf meinen rechner schalten
dann können uns das gemeinsam ansehen
wie das ganze aussieht
liebe kolleginnen augenblick ich muss
noch mal kurz hier das verschieben damit
man mich auch sehen kann so jetzt könnt
ihr auf meinen rechner schalten klagt da
haben wir es so dass ist die
präsentation können sie die aussehen
frau professor jan und bisschen erahnen
so und da gibt da gibt es eine da die
vierte welle hat begonnen schreibt er
einfach nur aktuelle lage da ist es die
frage was er damit meint also sie würden
sagen für deutschland kann man das so
noch nicht hundertprozentig sagen er hat
gesagt die grippewelle hat begonnen
das heißt die zahlen haben anbieter dass
es hat begonnen dass die zahlen wieder
ansteigen
das sehen wir alle das zeigen uns die
zahlen ja aber eine welle ist ja dadurch
gekennzeichnet dass sie sehr hoch geht
und dann wieder runter geht und das sehe
ich jetzt im moment in den zahlen noch
nicht aber dass das ein erstes zeichen
einer beginnenden sein kann da wirklich
ein wiener zustimmen
die frage ist jetzt was machen wir wir
haben ja durchaus jetzt mittel und wege
diese infektion zu verhindern sprich wir
haben verschiedene
impfstoffe die jetzt auch eigentlich
breit verfügbar sind wir alle können uns
impfen lassen es gibt ja keine
beschränkungen mehr
aber wir stellen fest gerade mal die
hälfte der erwachsenen in deutschland
ist durch geimpft und für die kinder
gibt es ja noch überhaupt keine
wirkliche empfehlung für die kinder
unter 12 wird gesagt in die ab 12
zwischen 12 und 18 da wird gesagt ihr
könnt aber wir empfehlen es nicht von
der ständigen impfkommission axel konrad
fasst man den aktuellen im stand für uns
zusammen fünf impfungen in der sekunde
auch wenn sich das tempo in den
vergangenen wochen halbiert hat es geht
immer noch deutlich voran
mindestens einmal geimpft sind in
deutschland mittlerweile gut 60 prozent
der bevölkerung und mehr als die hälfte
hat bereits den vollständigen impfschutz
am höchsten ist die impfquote bei den
über 60-jährigen knapp 74 prozent haben
die doppel impfung exakt 50 prozent sind
es bei den 18 bis 59 jährigen bei den 12
bis 17 jährigen ist die quote 11,4
deutlich am meisten impfstoff wurde in
den impfzentren gespritzt bei den
bundesländern ein klares
west-ost-gefälle hinsichtlich der
einfach geimpften spitzenreiter bremen
und das saarland schlusslicht der
thüringen und sachsen
seit beginn dieses beitrages wurden
statistisch übrigens 250 menschen in
deutschland geimpft
professor kreuzer da ist noch ein
bisschen luft nach oben ich guck mal
hier in die kommentare
da gibt es dann so anfragen wie von
jochen brückner was haben die menschen
bloß für ein problem mit der impfung
oder andere wortmeldung von skies sowie
herdenimmunität gibt es auch ohne
impfung erst mal die frage an sie
überrascht es sie dass die
impfbereitschaft jetzt doch so schnell
nachgelassen hat nachdem ja doch sehr
rasant angestiegen ist und man sich
beinahe um die termine geprügelt hat ich
habe das ehrlich gesagt befürchtet die
impfbereitschaft war da hoch wo man
einfach viele infektionen gesehen hat
und jetzt ist wenig in wenige
infektionsgeschehen da und dann sehen
wie leute das natürlich nicht so als
priorität an
ich glaube schon dass sich das im herbst
noch mal wieder ein landwirt und ich
glaube macht wir uns auch immer wieder
klar machen müssen es gibt ja zwei
motivationen vereinigung vor
das eine ist der
regenschutz und das andere ist der
gesellschaftliche schutz und die
gesellschaftliche bedeutung wie gesagt
hat wenn ich im gm spinnen und nicht
mehr zum fortschreiten dass das
infektionsgeschehen beitrage
und ich glaube das wird schon den
menschen im herbst dann doch mal wieder
bewusster werden ich glaube schon dass
wir da noch mal auch ein anstieg der
änderungen bekommen aber hier gibt es
jetzt tatsächlich die frage macht der
herren nominiert immunität ohne
impfungen also wird man die erreichen
und auch eine frage die dazu passt von
wolfgang auf youtube was würde passieren
ohne medikation also wenn man es einfach
durchlaufen lässt was ist denn da ihre
prognose natürlich wird meine
herdenimmunität auch irgendwann
erreichen wenn man nicht impft als wir
jetzt gar keinen impfstoff hätten und
das ganze würde durch rauschen dann
hätten wir auch irgendwann sehr viele
infizierte dass man die immunität
komplette reich bei dieser infektion
wage ich zu bezweifeln denn es gibt kein
corona virus das bisher gelungen ist das
hat verschiedene gründe
deshalb zum ersten den grund dass die
immunität wenn ich die infektion
durchgemacht habe einfach nicht so lange
anhält bei allen koalieren ist das zwölf
maximal 24 monate und dann müsste ich
mich ja ständig wieder infizieren vor
versagen als gewesener meine immunität
aufrechtzuerhalten und der zweite grund
ist ich an diese infektion auch nicht
mehr irgendwo komplett ausrotten in der
menschheit das ist nicht polier und das
ist nicht trocken und das ist auch nicht
neu sei wir haben hier ist ja mit einer
infektion zu tun wo es eine tierische
quelle gibt das heißt die auch immer
wieder zurückkommen kann in die
menschliche population und weltweit
haben wir einfach noch nicht sehr viele
menschen geht also auch aus allen
ländern hören wir natürlich ständig wie
der infektionen zurückgekommen also eine
herdenimmunität zu erreichen die
bedeuten würde
es gibt gar kein infektionsgeschehen in
deutschland mehr das halte ich für sehr
sehr schwierig erreichbar
jetzt haben wir ja gesehen die impfrate
könnte besser sein
die wird auch steigen noch aber
wahrscheinlich nicht so stark wie
benötigt und das lka hat einmal
modelliert was die verschiedenen
impfraten dann für die instanzen und
dann auch für die
krankenhausaufenthalte intensivbetten
belegungen heißen können das gehört
zusammen anschauen und sie können dass
das vielleicht ein bisschen genauer
erläutern wir schauen mal hier auf die
erste grafik das ist quasi der mögliche
verlauf der vierten welle sieben tage
incidents mit einer verhaltensänderung
das heißt kontakt beschränkungen sind
wieder in kraft
und da sehen wir bei einer impfquote von
75 prozent die er wahrscheinlich
schwierig zu erreichen ist gerade immer
noch eine instanz von der ungefähr 140
130 bei 85 prozent geimpften sind wir
unter 100 und bei 95% auch unter 100
also impfung plus verhaltensänderungen
wenn wir aber sehen dass wir keine
verhaltensänderung durchführen
dann sehe das ganze so aus da kommt dass
die nächste grafik einmal aufbauen also
auch wieder sieben tage incidents mit
75% impfung also auch das was wir noch
nicht erreicht haben hätten wir dann im
januar nach dieser modellierung schon
eine instanz von über 400 mit 85 prozent
im quote immer noch 300 und mit 95
prozent geimpften immer noch 200 und da
stellt sich mir jetzt die frage frau
professor protzer ist diese also die
letzte grafik die wir gesehen haben wir
sind zwar geimpft aber wir machen keine
verhaltensänderung haben dann diese
incidents wert erhalten sie dann diese
infektion noch für kontrollierbar nicht
mehr aber schon doch so gering dass man
sagen kann da werden die krankenhäuser
eventuell noch mit klarkommen wir haben
jetzt hier die grafik der zwölf- bis 59
jährigen gesehen nicht die grafik 60plus
und wir wissen dass die zwölf- bis
59-jährigen natürlich nicht so hohes
risiko haben ins krankenhaus zu kommen
das ist ein bisschen schwer
vorherzusagen wie dann wirklich die
belastung der krankenhäuser sein wird
die wird natürlich schon höher sein als
jetzt im moment ist aber ob das dann
schon zu einer überlastung führt wenn
wir eine quote von 75% hätten da bin ich
mir nicht so ganz sicher und man muss
sagen automatisch waren die menschen ja
immer wieder eine verhaltensänderung
wenn sie jetzt nach england schauen wo
eigentlich die massnahmen weitestgehend
aufgehoben sind und die zahlen über 3
jahrhundert waren gehen sie dann
trotzdem plötzlich nach unten warum weil
die menschen die zahlen sehen weil sie
verstehen oder ist wieder sehr viel
infektionsgeschehen und natürlich sich
wieder entsprechend verhalten das haben
wir alle inzwischen gelernt wie wir uns
verhalten sollen damit dass sich eben
nicht so schnell ausbreitet gucken wir
es gleich noch mal genauer an wie es in
england aussieht wir haben hier nochmal
eine weitere grafik die genau sich mit
diesen intensivbetten beschäftigt da
können wir auch mal gucken wie das ganze
aussieht mit den verschiedenen
impfquoten also einmal intensiv
medizinische behandlungen mit einer
verhaltensänderung bei den verschiedenen
im quoten also bei 75 prozent und einer
verhaltensänderung hätten wir noch 2000
intensive medizinische behandlungen im
januar so als pique und die zahlen
darunter sind dann ja fast die hälfte
und noch weniger und wenn wir sehen wir
haben keine verhaltensänderungen
verändern sich die kurven wie folgt da
geht es dann bei 75 prozent sehen wir
gleich deutlich nach oben 7000
intensivmedizinische behandlung im
januar 22 nächsten jahres wäre so der
peak und bei 85 prozent legen wir so bei
ungefähr viereinhalb tausend die frage
die ich mir jetzt stelle einmal ganz
genau verhaltensänderungen was meinen
sie damit also das heißt ja nicht gleich
ein shutter und das heißt ja dann
tatsächlich eine freiwillige kontakt
reduzierung oder absolut das ist eine
freiwillige kontakt reduzierung das
heißt halt dass man ja einfach in
innenräumen nicht in ganz tolle räume
hinein geht das heißt vermutlich auch
dass man in engen in den räumen in
räumen wo es eng wird weiterhin der
maske trägt sind viele maßnahmen die die
ganz persönlich jeder einzelne für sich
dann entscheidet das er eben vielleicht
mich ins restaurant nicht in die bar
geht oder die auch entschieden werden
die amerikaner haben jetzt gerade in
innenräumen zum beispiel die masten
pflicht wieder eingeführt weil eben die
zahlen wieder deutlich hoch gegangen
sind und den effekt den sieht man dann
auch sofort jetzt wenn wir den boliden
gesehen von 7.000 bei 75 prozent
geimpften da ist die frage ob wir das
überhaupt erreichen ohne
verhaltensänderungen aber die frage die
sich jetzt johannes thiele gestellt hat
ob die zahl der kranken
house einweisungen haben wir soeben
schon gesprochen überhaupt ein wirksamer
indikator ist denn er meint wenn die
menschen im krankenhaus landen ist das
doch eigentlich schon zu spät
entgegenzusteuern
weil die ja schon eine weile krank war
und wahrscheinlich auch weiter andere
menschen angesteckt haben könnten oder
das problem haben wir natürlich immer
ich bin ja ansteckend ganz am anfang der
infektion durch symptome bekomme und da
werde ich typischerweise auch nicht
getestet also auch die testung kommt
eigentlich schon immer ein bisschen zu
spät mit aber einfach nicht anders und
die krankenhauseinweisung findet im
durchschnitt sieben tage nach der
infektion stadt und die sieben tage
since i denn es dauert natürlich auch
immer oder das dann auch immer gemittelt
über sieben tage
also ich bin wenn ich das gleich noch
mal autofahren vergleiche habe ich mit
kleinen den situationen den blick aus
der frontscheibe und kam nach vorne
schauen sondern ich gucke immer aus dem
seitenfenster raus und schaue mir an was
passiert denn gerade das haben sie
gerade schon angesprochen england gab es
diese verhaltens modifikationen schon
obwohl es ja im endeffekt keine
beschränkungen mehr gibt wir gucken uns
das mal ganz kurz an thomas garcia hat
das für uns zusammengefasst wie das
gerade dort aussieht auf der insel
party im pub feiern am freedom day seit
montag vergangener woche dürfen die
engländer das wieder mitten in corona
zeiten denn auch großbritannien erlebt
eine neue welle die zahl der infektionen
steigt aktuell auf knapp 40.000 und zwar
pro tag etwa doppelt so viele wie in der
vergangenen
auch die zahl der
krankenhauseinweisungen geht wieder nach
oben allerdings nicht so stark wie in
der fälle zuvor und auch die zahl der
toten steigt nur leicht an
im vergleich zur vergangenen entwicklung
da registrierte man täglich mehr als 400
sterbefälle briten feiern die freiheit
und die zahlen als erfolg also anschauen
dann muss man doch eigentlich
feststellen dass die warnungen vom rkw
chef jeder der sagt wir müssen aufpassen
vorsicht vor der vierten welle
vielleicht ja sich doch nicht ganz so
dramatisch darstellen könnten zumindest
wenn wir dieses beispiel nehmen oder wie
sehen sie das
absolut das ist ja das was wir haben
anfangs schon diskutiert haben man muss
unterscheiden wie ist das
infektionsgeschehen und wie ist das
krankheitsgeschehen und das
krankheitsgeschehen wenn ich wie
bewerteten teil der bevölkerung wie also
ein risiko haben schwer krank zu gehen
geschützt und das ambiente
die haben ja schon fast 80 prozent ihrer
über 60 jährigen geben dann geht
natürlich die anzahl der
krankenhauseinweisungen und viel
langsamer hoch als dass zu zeiten vor
der impfung war dann geht die zahl der
intensivbetten belegungen langsam auch
ob und natürlich auch die zahl der toten
deutlich langsamer
das heißt die warnung von herrn wieder
würden sie so nicht unterschreiben
man hat ja nicht gesagt dass die welle
genauso stark wird wie die letzte welle
hat nur gesagt wir sind am beginn einer
neuen welle und das ist natürlich nicht
verkehr
das können wir das von den briten lernen
also würden sie empfehlen dass wir das
genauso machen wie dass die britische
regierung also zumindest für england
beschlossen hat in schottland und wales
sieht das ja noch anders aus
oder halten sie das für jetzt keine gute
idee in england ist es ja auch nicht so
dass es gar keine maßnahmen
es gibt keine generellen vorschrift mehr
die fürs ganze land gelten aber
natürlich gibt es lokale maßnahmen also
wenn sie in london mit der tube waren
wollen dann müssen sie trotzdem
weiterhin der mars getragen und viele
andere städte haben auch ihre regionalen
lokalen maßnahmen ergriffen
insofern dass so ein bisschen vielleicht
freier zu lassen ist natürlich eine
möglichkeit andererseits hat man dann
wieder das problem was wir ja auch schon
hatten wo wir dann regional
unterschiedlich je nach bundesländern
unterschiedliche maßnahmen hatten was
ist für die menschen auf dauer schon
schwer zu verstehen und man muss ja dann
ständig nachschauen wo man sich gerade
befindet was gilt denn eigentlich hier
vor ort
ich persönlich finde es immer einfacher
wenn irgendwo einheitliches machen jetzt
gibt es hier bei uns in den kommentaren
auch einige user innen die nochmal nach
den schulen und nach den kindern fragen
das ist ja auch mal streit thema gewesen
im letzten jahr beispielsweise man
israel beschreibt frau professor
protzner müssten aus ihrer sicht die
schulen noch mal geschlossen werden weil
ja viele schüler/innen noch nicht
geimpft sind weil sie sich schlichtweg
in der altersgruppe 12 bis 15 jahre oder
darunter befinden also wird das auf uns
zukommen da gehen ja auch gerade studien
so ein bisschen auseinander und ich das
richtig gesehen habe wie gefährlich
jetzt diese data variante für kinder
gerade ist oder variante ist für die
kinder genau wie für die erwachsenen
sicherlich ansteckender als die alpha
variante die man bisher hatte und die so
richtig gute daten im von der
übertragung in den schulen haben wir mit
der delta variante natürlich noch mich
weil das jetzt gerade in fast allen
europäischen ländern einfach die
sommerzeit
was wir aus den vorherigen wählen wissen
ist dass in den klassenzimmern so lange
dort masken getragen werden
relativ wenig übertragung und passieren
die übertragungen passieren doch
hauptsächlich dann wieder im sozialen
bereich also betreffen dann vorwiegend
auch die oberstufen die 16 bis 18
jährigen
wie man meines erachtens bevorzugten
dies im prozess mit einschließen sollte
aber weniger bei den jüngeren in aus den
usa gibt auch eine studie die sagt durch
masken tragen kann ich dich um über 70
prozent der infektionen in den
klassenräumen verhindern
also das ist ja schon mit zahl jetzt
müssen wir noch über eine aktuelle
diskussion reden die gerade auch heute
wieder aufgepeppt ist nämlich die frage
nach der test flicht für reiserückkehrer
da würde ich gerne noch mal ihre
expertise in anspruch nehmen die
bundesregierung hat sich heute erstmal
nicht auf eine schnelle regelung einigen
können
das würden noch interne abstimmungen
laufen das sagte heute die
vize-regierungssprecherin ulrike demmer
in berlin
und das ganze soll es am 10 08
besprochen werden zwischen bund und
ländern
halten sie diese tests pflicht also
diese wirklich test nicht für alle
reiserückkehrer jetzt in den
sommerferien für sinnvoll klammer auch
auf auch für chinesen und geimpfte
klammer zu natürlich ist es so dass ich
als gemäss maurer em-start nicht null
chance haben sich anzustecken wenn der
impfstoff und so ist das bei der delta
variante 66 prozent für direktor
basierten impfstoffe und 88 prozent für
die em-arena impfstoffe wirksam ist dann
heißt es halt dass zwei von 30 nicht
anstecken wenn ich jetzt den auch
weniger impfstoff als beispiel nehmen
aber einer von dreien sich trotz dem
grundstück bei den anaheim stoffen sowie
plans minister aus england sich der
schutz 88 prozent vor ansteckungen
bezahlt aber trotzdem einer von zehn
steckt sich an
jetzt widmet frage wie groß ist mein
sicherheitsbedürfnis wenn ich sage die
die geimpften sollen auch getestet
werden dann will ich sehr sicher gehen
haben wir sagen ich möchte wirklich
möglichst einen der sich im urlaub
angesteckt hat unentdeckt nach
deutschland zurückreisen lassen wenn ich
sage gut ich beschränke die testungen
nur auf die ungeimpften dann lasse ich
halt diese kleinere risiko der geimpften
irgendwo außen vor
17 ist eine politische entscheidung wie
viel risiko ist man bereit einzugehen
und welche maßnahmen will man dann
endlich durchziehen wie us
wissenschaftler können da immer nur die
zahlenbasis dann können wir noch mal zum
ende zu der kernfrage die wir hier
aufgeworfen haben nämlich wie gefährlich
könnte diese vierte welle werden wo man
schweizer schreibt das kann doch keiner
ernsthaft beantworten können sie
trotzdem versuchen ja zu modellieren in
welchen fällen die welle wie für wen
gefährlich werden könnte das ist
tatsächlich immer schwierig insofern hat
er natürlich schon recht denn der blick
in die glaskugel ist immer sehr
risikoreich und wirklich gut beantworten
kann das einfach noch nicht genannt ich
glaube was man mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit sagen kann dass wir
wieder ein anstieg der zahlen im herbst
bekommen werden
was das konkret bedeutet für die
belegung unserer krankenhäuser um
zurückzukommen auch das auf das thema
welche krankheitslast noch dadurch
ausgelöst dass ist tatsächlich extrem
schwer vorherzusagen weil da natürlich
rein spielten viele infektionen sind das
wie hoch ist die in quote die wir bedarf
bis dahin haben welche maßnahmen gelten
weiter gilt die maske pflicht in
innenräumen weiter oder nicht gibt es
weiterhin kontakt beschränkungen ja oder
nein und zu welchen maßnahmen sind die
menschen auch persönlich einfach
freigelegt entstanden oder bereit und
ich glaube das ist tatsächlich extrem
schwer vorherzusagen was für mich sicher
ist dass wir so eine schwerere welle
wieder im letzten jahr hatten nicht mehr
gekommen
aber ich ahne es werden noch einige
diskussionen auf uns zukommen vielen
dank für pro frau professor protzer dass
sie sich heute für unsere fragen zur
verfügung gestellt haben und was ich
immer wieder wiederholen kann das sagen
ja alle expertinnen eigentlich die
impfquote wird entscheidend sein
hier kann auch die frage auf ob ich
geimpft bin ja ich bin geimpft
mittlerweile zweimal mit dem mma
impfstoff von der firma moderner morgen
ist die impfung dann auch aktiv weil 14
tage her und ich bin nicht ganz sicher
aber zumindest habe ich meinen stückchen
beigetragen ich glaube da kann frau
professor % auch froh sein
ich bedanke mich bei ihnen schöne grüße
nach münchen und bedanke mich bei euch
mitmachen fürs zuschauen und für eure
fragen und kommentare
wie gesagt bis zum nächsten live stream
macht's gut und tschüss